entire streets in nature's capital now
may are submerged heavy rain and floods
proved too much for retaining walls
along the neva river across the country
more than 12,000 homes have been
destroyed those who refuse to leave
save what they can sandbags are filled
to stop more water from flooding homes a
Neighborhood Watch keeps track of the
river levels 24-hours a day but it will
give gwangan authorities had urged
people who lived along the river to
prepare for the floods but many of us
didn't know where we could go more than
130,000 people have been affected by the
floods since June many displaced
families are now living in schools but
it's unclear how long they'll be allowed
to stay they worry they won't have a
home to go back to could amazing to some
time be some homes were flooded but
haven't crumbled yet in one day about
250 houses were totally demolished if
the rain keeps coming it will continue
to destroy crops have been destroyed and
infrastructure damaged but the
government says it can only offer
limited support volunteers are putting
up tents for the displaced it's not
meant as a long-term solution but for
those who've lost everything it's a
lifeline we're here to help build the
tents and shelters for the victims of
the flood these are people who had to
flee the banks of the neva river so we
just want to help our community the
country was already facing a crisis
extreme weather has caused a food
shortage in recent years violence linked
to Boko Haram has forced many from their
homes more than two million people are
in need of humanitarian aid the
government says the worst of the rain is
over for the threat to his population
remains both from flooding and the
ever-present risk of a cholera outbreak
katia lupus of a yawn al Jazeera